هل لديك اي تصور
للحد من الهجره غير الشرعيه
على النطاق الاوروبي وياخذ بعين الاعتبار
مصالحنا وايضا مصلحه المحتاجين حقا للهجره
يمكنهم من خلالها تقديم طلبات للحمايه او
انسانيه ومن ثم يتم تقيمها حق الاشخاص في
الدخول الى اوروبا
ولاحقا عندما نحدد الاشخاص ذوي الاحقيه
نحن من نتولات تنظيم عمليه دخولهم الى
اوروبا عبر رحلات امنه وعبر برامج استقبال
وتوجيه وادماج وفي نفس الوقت نبلغ من لا
يحق لهم الهجره وفقا للمعايير المشتركه
بانه لا يمكنهم دخول اوروبا واعتقد ان هذا
امر اساسي هو الذي وحده يمكنه ان يمنحنا
القدره على منح الاولويه لمن يستحقوه
بامكاننا اليوم ان نرى ان اولئك المغادرين
انطلاقا من افريقيا ليسوا هم الاشخاص
الاضعف او انهم لم يحضن بالاولويه في
الهجره او ان ظروفهم صعبه حقا لدرجه انه
لا بديل لهم عن الهجره وانما هم اشخاص
قادرون اعلى دفع الاف الدولارات لشبكات
الجريمه المنظمه للقيام برحلات غير مضمون
وهذا وحده ما يجعلنا قادرين على ان نلتفت
عندها الى من يعيشون في اوضاع صعبه للغايه
في افريقيا